hey everyone so a lot of you have been
asking me how much do Solutions
Architects get paid at AWS and how does
that compare with other roles in other
companies in this video I'm joined by
Zahir the co-founder of levels.fyi which
is a platform that helps compare career
levels and salaries across different
companies so here was previously a
software engineer at AWS and decided to
quit his job around three years ago to
work on levels.fyi full-time if you're
someone looking to land a job in the
cloud industry I'd highly recommend
watching this video to the end because
the here not only breaks down how much
AWS Solutions Architects get paid but
also how to figure out how much you
should get paid based on different
factors like your location your role and
years of experience let's get into it
he's here how are you doing today hey
I'm doing great nice to be here so to
start off with you want to tell the
viewers a bit about yourself and
levels.fyi yeah absolutely so yeah my
name is Dean I'm one of the co-founders
of levels.fyi levels.fia if you haven't
heard of it our mission is to help
professionals build better careers and
we do that by collecting data and
information about companies and careers
and helping people essentially explore
that data so a lot of people come to the
site to see salaries predominantly and
then we also help people compare career
ladders and all sorts of things my
background I'm a software engineer I
started my career at LinkedIn out of
college so I worked there as a software
engineer I worked on the messaging team
building like messaging products got
promoted there to a senior engineer and
then I hopped over to Amazon and I was
in Amazon web services AWS and I was a
senior engineer over there awesome so
getting straight into it and this is a
question I get asked all the time how
much do Solutions Architects actually
get paid at AWS and one of the factors
that determines someone's salary the
biggest factor and this is important for
like negotiations as well is essentially
the level that you get placed at so
where do you fall on the career ladder
companies decide how to pay people based
on like the level and location years of
experience plays sometimes a factor but
really it comes down to the level and
within a level you might have someone
that's like five years of experience and
you might have someone that has 15 years
of experience so really you know that
the level is really what you want to
look at when you're comparing pay and in
terms of like pay how much do they
actually get paid again depends on
location level but I can tell you at
least in like the US the pay will start
out around like 160k for like a L4
solution architect and then at the next
level you're going up to around 215 000
and it goes all the way up to even like
430 000 at the principal level and it
may be even higher these are like some
of the medians that we've been able to
collect for higher levels the pay
continues to go up and up it really just
depends on the level and location great
thanks so much for explaining the
different factors I know Company
benefits are also an important part of
conversation so how should people think
about benefits and perks when it comes
to their total compensation package yeah
benefits are part of the total rewards
package that a company gives you it's
important to factor in benefits a lot of
different companies have widely varying
benefits and oftentimes benefit fits can
add even tens of thousands of dollars in
the amount that you're getting paid you
know it may not be direct monetary
compensation but it's still something
that adds value to your paycheck and to
what you take home so as an example a
lot of companies will have like
retirement benefits and they may be
contributing to your retirement accounts
or they may have you know free lunch
breakfast dinner things like that and
what we do is we actually try to
quantify those benefits at levels.fyi as
well so on the site you can actually see
how we quantify benefits and try to
assign like a dollar value to how much a
company's benefits are for example
Amazon we've Quantified it to around
seven thousand dollars of benefits per
year that a person would be receiving in
addition to their total compensation
again it's super important when you take
that into account
um you know there may be one company
that offers slightly less dollar
competition in terms of salaries but
they may offer much better benefits and
depending on your personal situation as
well for example if you have like health
issues or if you need a certain thing we
totally recommend that people take those
into account try to customize it to your
situation in terms of the companies that
you're selecting amazing yeah I love the
advice around trying to tailor it based
on your own personal situation
so how do you find out the approximate
salary based on the factors that you
mentioned do you want to show us a quick
demo yeah of course let's do it so here
we are on the main page of the website
go to let
www.levels.fyi what you're looking at
here is the career ladders at different
companies so you can see for example
Google Facebook and I'll just pull in
Amazon over here and so you can see for
example like I was talking about pays
based on the level so the first level at
Amazon is like sde1 or L4 engineer and
then it goes up to L5 and so on and so
forth if you click we'll show you the
compensation for it this is specifically
for software development engineer but
let's say we want to see solution
architect salaries well you can search
solution architect you can go ahead and
click on the job family and here we are
on the solution architect page and what
we're looking at now is the US median
compensation for solution Architects
right this is across all companies
across all kind of data points
um you know let's say we want to look at
at the pay in Australia now you can see
this is what the median that we have 145
000 and then you can also see the
percentiles and now as we kind of go
down here you can see all of the
different submissions that people have
submitted so it looks like someone at
Amazon has a sa3 so the third level
essentially that 16 years of experience
is making 273 000 that's massive that's
great that's awesome and you know now we
can click into this and see a bit more
details so I'm here on the Amazon page
you can also get to it if you search
Amazon and I'm going to go to solution
architect
and this page is really awesome you can
see how pay progresses across different
levels and so we can see that people are
starting out at roughly like the 200-ish
range a little less than 200 and then
they're moving on to 215 a little bit
higher 200s and you can see kind of like
the chart of the histogram in some sense
of how it goes up for each level and it
gets all the way up to like the 600s for
the highest levels and again there's
different pages for each of the
different levels so let's say we want to
look at the first entry level this is
for the US I'll change it to Australia
here and we can see that at the first
level at Amazon if you were to join
Amazon as a solution architect at the
first level you'd be making around
eighty seven thousand dollars and you
can kind of see all of the data that we
have for it over here as well yeah so
this is um how you can use the site to
find salaries that are relevant for you
and find the data that's for your
company as well as for your role before
we continue our conversation with zaheer
I'd like to take a moment to introduce
today's video sponsor nordpass if you're
anything like me you'll probably also
find it hard to remember the pastors to
all the accounts you create lordpass
offers a secure password management tool
and a nor pass business password manager
makes it easy for you to store and
manage passwords the platform helps ease
the burden of access to business
accounts making it possible for you and
your team to work across devices and
apps uninterrupted as we go into the
admin view you can see that there are
options to invite additional team
members observe password security create
groups and check user activity I've
started to store my own passwords on
nodpass to save me the hassle of having
to press the forgot password button
every time I can't remember my
credentials see node past business in
action now with a three month free trial
by clicking the link in the description
below and using the code Techwood Lucy
now let's get back to the video so here
most of our viewers are probably those
who are at the start of their Cloud
journey and looking to understand
salaries better what advice would you
like to leave with them the biggest
advice I have for folks that are
starting their careers is try and get an
internship internships are the easiest
way to get a full-time job and I mean
actually I started off my career at
LinkedIn and the way I got my job at
LinkedIn is because I interned at
LinkedIn when I was in college and so
you know internships the approval rating
from intern to hire tends to be around
like 50 to 80 percent so about 50 to 80
percent of people that get an internship
tend to get hired it's like a full-time
role and so it's super super important
to actually get internships and then the
other advice I have around pay and
salaries is oftentimes you know a lot of
new grad offers you typically can't
negotiate as much but even if you're one
year in your career or two years plus in
your career always always negotiate your
job offers you could be leaving
literally thousands of dollars on the
table and oftentimes all it takes is
just asking them for an increase even if
you don't have a competing offer you
really just want to make the case and
try shooting your shot and asking and
you can do it in a very nice way
essentially that doesn't put off the
company so saying hey I really love this
off offer but would we be able to get to
this number and I'd be super excited to
join that said I love the team I love
the company and would still be happy
regardless alright so this brings us to
the end of this video please give it a
like if you learned something new about
tech salaries and I'll see you soon bye
for now